all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place
let's go to spencer from wyoming spencer
you were on the air
hi david how are you i'm doing well
thank you uh it's an honor to talk to
you i'm glad you called on me thank you
my pleasure
i just i i wanted to bring up a question
i'm originally from pennsylvania okay
and
i lived in a community near gettysburg
and we started a petition to rename all
the streets named after confederate
generals to union okay
um and everyone in the community hated
it
like all the older folks specifically
um
and eventually i said if we could just
get one street sign change i would call
that a win
and i'm wondering what you think of you
know
we have majority in the senate house and
white house yep um
but should we be focusing on baby steps
or should we be focusing on
like in my example should i have been
happy with just one street change or
is it is it more important to really
push what you believe in um to be right
oh man this is this i mean this is a
really tough and big issue so i think we
should take any wins we can get okay so
with with the street signs example the
street names example
if you want every street name
confederate street name changed but all
that can be done because of the
circumstances politically is one that
one has changed
you still take it right you still take
it but at the same time you you keep
pushing for more i think for me the
other thing is
i'm all about changing you know the
school names you know i don't want
general robert e lee high school or
whatever and street i'm i'm fine with
that but i sometimes worry
that too much energy is going into
things like changing street names or
taking down statues when there are much
more substantive issues i get that
you've got you know you rectify the
language to try to impact culture i get
the concept of that and so calling us
calling a street by a different name can
sort of at a base level change how we
think about things and think about
history i also think the left needs to
be careful not to overplay
our hand on things like street names
although we should work on them and we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
but that's a really complicated question
but to go to we should take any wins we
can get maybe the only thing that was
possible there was the one one street
name you know
yeah
it was um nathan bedford forest who
which forrest gump is named after it was
that street but he lived on it
so we were able to get that one change
but people were just you know they
started questioning you know the civil
war wasn't even about slavery it was it
was ugly but yeah yeah it really made me
question like should i be happy with
that that was last summer i was like
should i be happy with what we've done
here or should i wanted more but i think
you you raised some good points you
should want more but you should be happy
that you were able to get something i
guess what was the street name changed
to out of curiosity was it changing like
oak street or something
um no so all the other streets were
union generals so it actually turned
into lincoln we didn't have a lincoln
believe it or not okay all right well um
so you know say what you want about abe
lincoln but better than uh confederate
general i would say i would say so i
would say so all right well keep on
fighting you know yeah thank you all
right very good
um
okay
let's go next to
uh oh this is how about elias from
helsinki you're on the air
hello hello yes i can
uh excellent uh congratulations for the
billion views david thank you i couldn't
have done it without you elias
yeah i've been
following you for uh i think about seven
years or something you're probably good
for a couple thousand views i would say
i had no doubt yeah so yeah i actually
want to ask you a a bit of a more
fundamental question regarding your uh
political views so i have to elias i
know you said you're in helsinki are you
scottish
uh no no no
no i'm finnish actually oh wow okay
yeah
uh sorry about the accent i i do have
some scottish friends so i suppose they
might have a nippy it's fascinating all
right go on i apologize for interrupting
yeah no problem so yeah uh i think
you've said that you're um
in in some sense in favor of the uh sort
of nordic model
ie a source of capitalistic system with
the
socialistic uh policies
am i describing that correctly yeah i
don't call them social i i don't call it
a capitalist system with socialist
policies the way i describe social
democracy is um
a
socially
uh conscious
well-regulated form of capitalism that's
the way i describe it
yeah okay i think that's fair and uh
yeah i basically if i'm thinking
practically i'm i'm uh
uh
i i would say that's my
basically my well my basic uh political
views as well
uh but uh if if i'm thinking well i
idealistically or hypothetically myself
i i would actually be much more uh in
favor of actual actual social issue or
communism uh if that was actually
practical so obviously i don't think
it's really that practical so is we
don't live in a vacuum but uh
if we're just thinking hypothetically
would you be in favor of uh
more actual actual socialistic or
communistic policies no no i am not a
socialist or a communist i uh don't
believe that um um the means of
production should be socially owned i
certainly don't believe that they should
be government owned i think that people
should be free to
um own businesses and determine uh for
themselves sort of uh to what degree
they want to
be entrepreneurs i don't believe that um
the government
should be
allocating
resources
in in most cases i'm fine with using
market systems to allocate resources in
many cases although i think in certain
areas
uh things should be outside of the
market healthcare education you know
i've spoken about it before
um and i also would not be in favor of a
government imposing that the means of
production must be socially owned or
owned by the government now if
individual businesses want to decide for
themselves we will be a cooperative i am
all for that 100
um but no i i would not um
want to impose socialism or communism
those are not my views
okay um yeah that's that's a shame i i
think that's an unsubscribe for me okay
very good well thank you elias just
kidding just kidding yeah hey in all
seriousness though uh how late is the
sun out in helsinki right
now uh right now um
i think it's up about uh
or it's it would be setting at around
eight i know maybe nine oh that's
earlier than i thought helsinki was far
enough north where you had a very long
day in uh in in the summer
yeah it is but it's it's not that bad
yet oh okay uh yeah it'll be a couple of
months since uh before it's uh
uh dark at uh at this time
i see japan but so wait when in the
middle of december when does the sun go
down how early does it set
probably at five or something oh wow
it's not that different than the
northeast all right well thank i
appreciate the call thanks for
clarifying for me all right cheers david
okay there's elias from helsinki
a beautiful phone call i have to tell
you
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video